hello everybody my name is Joe and I'm
speaking at guru cow this is a dream
come true but I don't have a lot of time
so I gotta get right to it
first I run this company we're
sponsoring the conference go Rico if you
are great at what you do
then we're hiring I'm writing this book
it's called the well grounded rubyist
the third edition with my good friend
and mentor David Black and I started
writing Ruby a long time ago I started
writing Ruby back in 2007 when we were
all still arguing about whether or not
Tony died at the end of Sopranos and
programming was different back in 2007 I
was being paid to write Ruby which was
amazing and not many people were and
version 186 was hot off the presses we
loved it which was a good thing because
we almost didn't get any more after that
everybody I knew including myself had
our hopes riding on this company called
Twitter because it was being written in
Ruby we didn't totally know what it was
we all felt like our own career
trajectory had a lot to do with the
success or failure of Twitter and I
think we were probably right this is
what Twitter looked like when I signed
up nobody had come and tried to redefine
the word cloud Heroku wouldn't be out
till 2009 so we all just wrote our own
deployment but that was not the worst of
it every rubyist wrote their own
authentication that is a pause for
dramatic effect every Ruby hissed there
was no such thing as worden there was no
such thing as devise Melissa wanna give
a great talk about encryption that could
not have been spoken in 2007 we just did
it ourselves till finally Chad Fowler
brought some sanity to the world by
writing rails recipes which every Rubeus
bought because there was a chapter about
how to authenticate your users right
underneath that helpfully authorizing
your users Ruby's future was uncertain
and this was really exciting we all had
this big release this big Ruby 2 in the
sky that was coming someday probably
but we had a whole bunch more people it
was not just the Japanese language it
was not just an American language it was
never just an American language there
were people from all over the world
contributing and we couldn't quite
decide where we were gonna go and how we
were gonna get there we couldn't agree
on anything from utf-8 to concurrency so
ruby won 8-6 was out on Christmas Day of
2007 won 9-0 came out and it was like a
lump of coal and everybody stockings
it wasn't production-ready we knew it
was in production ready what we didn't
know was that it would be 14 months
before a new point release of 1 9 would
come out in the meantime we had 187 I
talked to Mike D'Alessio about this and
he said 187 felt like a warm hug that's
a nice way to put it and certainly it's
shipped with Macs and so this was big
news this was cool unfortunately it did
not work with rails 2 or rails 2.1 which
were the only ones that were available
and so if you were using rails you
couldn't use the 187 until Ruby
Enterprise Edition came along which was
awesome it had green threads it was
highly optimized it ran way faster than
186 it had an unfortunate name anybody
coming from the Java world with the
experience of j2ee did not want to see
the words Enterprise Edition after Ruby
but it was a great step in the right
direction finally in 2009 we got version
one nine one things started to get on
the right track 192 193 finally - oh
this was a long time this took six years
this took from the end of The Sopranos
to the start of Rick and Morty for us to
go from 186 to Ruby - but we didn't care
because we made it
Twitter and LinkedIn and github were the
darlings of the tech community and they
were written in Ruby air B&B SoundCloud
Groupon and a dozen other companies you
could name we're hot on their tail and
they were all written in Ruby we felt
like we made it and we had this we had
speed features community we had meta
programming techniques as a first-class
citizen we had better garbage collection
we had a totally rewritten vm by KO ichi
sasada we have Ruby quiz comm do you
understand how cool Ruby quiz comm was
our heroes of the Ruby community would
get together solve little Ruby quizzes
and post their answers online for all
all of us to look at their how they
write code it was the coolest thing you
can think of Ryan Bates was giving us
rails casts every week and you could
talk to the people who are implementing
Ruby everyday on Ruby talk yet somehow
we went from that unbridled excitement
to sheer boredom I don't know when it
happened but it happened I think part of
it had to do with the fact that we all
looked at Ruby as this shooting star
that was gonna come out and was gonna
topple the big boys
no more Java no more Python and I think
we had our pride wrapped up in that you
know it was like well if Ruby's so much
better than Java and Python then why are
all these people still writing Java and
Python but the fact is Ruby made it
Ruby has its place in the world it's not
going anywhere the real question is
where do you stand with Ruby and when I
asked that question I get a lot of
answers back the most popular is this
one which I don't like well you know I
really don't like Rails well then stop
writing rails
stops just stop doing it today ruby is
not rails you are not at a rails
conference David H Hanson will shed zero
tears if you leave the rails community
today the next thing that comes up and
this is frequent is well I think that
object-oriented programming could be a
little bit dangerous it's over sharing
there's mutated state and I think
functional programming is the way to go
and oh my god is that a boring argument
look object-oriented programming has
been around since the 1960s and it's not
going anywhere
functional programming has been around
even longer and it's going to bury
everybody in this room seriously
does anybody here think they're gonna
outlive Lisp I don't even think I'm
gonna outlive Haskell but by all means
you should go learn some functional
languages Dave Thomas told us to go
learn a new language every single year
the point is that you should go and
learn some languages and then bring them
back to your home language bring what
you've learned back go learn every
single language on this list except the
ones I made up
and start Ruby light it writing Ruby
like it's 2018 which starts with
realizing that some of the stuff has
been around since at least 2013
higher-order functions referential
transparency continuations look this has
been around for at least five years you
should be doing it people are doing it
and now if you look at everything that's
been coming along since Ruby 2/5
released in Christmas of last year we've
got itself
we've got yield self which is gonna be
renamed to then we've got currying of
procs and methods and we've got myriad
improvements to threads and concurrency
and I'm gonna get to why in a second but
that's writing Ruby like it's 2018
that's taking advantage of what's
actually happening in the Ruby community
today and there are people doing it
here's a whole bunch of projects that
are doing just that they're writing
cutting-edge Ruby code these are these
are founded by people who came into the
Ruby community saw Ruby and liked what
they saw saw how most people were using
Ruby and said I think we can do better
and they did they're doing it right now
you need to check these projects out how
are they doing it they're employing
better practices they are writing code
against boundaries they are isolating
Honami is isolating views from templates
and it's got class-based controller
actions for easier testing the celluloid
project is I'm sorry the rrom project is
separating application logic from
persistence details dry our B project
has dependency injection turns out that
was a good idea and we just didn't do it
for 10 years well we can start now
celluloid has fault-tolerant concurrency
almost all of these projects are making
things better and easier to test which
is really important and strict datatypes
and Static typing are here so why are
all these things happen why am i begging
you to write Ruby like it's 2018 well
because again we've got this big great
Ruby release in the sky coming it's
called Ruby 3 and it's gonna come soon
we think it was announced two years ago
we're halfway to when we think it might
be released it's starting to feel a
whole lot like 2007 again
and there are some big promises coming
with it static typing is one of them but
guess what that's already here dry RB
has dry types you could check it out
right now on June first stripe released
a beta version of of sorbet you can go
to sorbet dot run as soon as I'm done
with this talk and check it out for
yourself it's awesome so that's here
another thing that's here Ruby running
three times faster has a lot to do with
frozen string literals and everybody who
that I've talked to you thinks that
frozen string literals are boring but
it's only boring because frozen string
literals oh they work fine in my app
well nobody cares about your twenty
thousand line crappy little app what
they care about is the fact that every
gem ever written since the beginning of
time that's still being used by any
project is gonna break we're gonna make
frozen string literals default and we're
gonna blow up the entire world of Ruby
nobody has an answer for how to roll
this out nobody not Yehuda Katz not Matz
but you can you could suggest you can
get involved the really big thing the
really big news is Ruby guilds Co Ichi
sasada who we owe our Ruby lives to in
many ways is writing Ruby guilds he's
going to conquer the global interpreter
lock those are my words but he's going
to conquer this and he's going to
abstract that away or conquer it so that
we can not just write concurrent Ruby we
can actually run parallel Ruby
multi-core processing we can we have
mutations safe concurrency these are
things that we did not even imagine
could be done in 186 and are now being
promised today and that's why when you
see things like method currying and all
of these advances in functional
programming paradigms this is why it's
because of what's coming and if you're
going to be ready for what's coming then
you need to start using these techniques
today and you don't need to go to
another language to do them you can do
them right here in Ruby to me it feels
like we're back in 2007 with our iPod
shuffles we have this great big release
in the sky we are underdogs again
there's a lot of doubt over whether or
not we'll get to those great big
features that I just mentioned and here
we are chugging along the fact is that
it's exciting without the threat of
utter failure none of this would be
exciting so we don't know if we're gonna
get there we don't know if there'll be a
ruby 3 and with wheat and when we get
there we don't know if anybody's gonna
use it just like we were back here I
suggest getting excited about that I
suggest getting yourself involved
getting yourself involved in the
conversation relearning learning new
languages and bringing them back and
strap in this is a great time to be a
rubyist thank you all